décembre est notre invité politique ce
matin c'est laurent saint martin bonjour
je
vous êtes rapporteur général du budget à
l'assemblée nationale candidat aux
législatives dans le val de marne sous
l'étiquette ensemble c'est l'étiquette
prix regroupe les candidats de la
majorité présidentielle on est ensemble
pendant 1 minute pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par fabrice
veysseyre dont le groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
pour aurillac bonjour de rang
saint-martin beaux jours laurent saint
martin premier conseil des ministres ce
matin pour le nouveau gouvernement bord
d'un gouvernement qui est déjà dans
l'atome monde puisque damien abad est
accusé de viol par deux femmes pour des
faits qui se seraient déroulés en 2010
et en 2011 l'observatoire des violences
sexistes et sexuelles a saisi la
république en marche avant sa nomination
d'anne abad se défend on le précise un
des faits qui lui sont reprochés d'une
des plantes a été classée sans suite
mais quand même peut-il rester au
gouvernement laurence allard écoutez
j'ai pas de commentaire différents à
faire de ce qu'a dit la première
ministre elle même elle a été très clair
il n'y avait pas connaissance de ces
faits là au moment de la composition du
gouvernement
il ya eu je crois n'a faire classer sans
suite et puis si la justice venait à
rouvrir une enquête et s'il y avait
après des poursuites alors le
gouvernement prendra ses responsabilités
mais
je crois que c'est effectivement ce qui
est fait ou en cas de condamnation en
fonction des faits mais vous savez faut
dans ces cas là toujours être
extrêmement prudent à l'heure où on se
parle il faut beaucoup mieux permettre
aux femmes de libérer leur parole ça je
crois qu'on doit être intraitable à
dessus elisabeth bornes l'a bien dit
faut mettre davantage de conditions
possiblement
permettant aux femmes de porter plainte
plus facilement être davantage à
l'écouté il faut aussi que en l'espèce
quand damien abad est accusée par ces
femmes-là lui permettent de se défendre
et donc de ne pas faire justice avant
que celle ci soit saisie est donc
surtout ne pas le faire sur des plateaux
de télé c'est ça qui est dangereux c'est
de ne pas rendre près coupable un homme
quand il peut y avoir des plaintes qui
sont portées contre lui donc je crois
qu'à ce stade c'est vraiment bien et a
droit de laisser la justice si le cas
échéant elle est saisie de faire son
travail rien de plus l'attaquant des
fennecs l'observatoire des violences
sexuelles et sexistes et dit avoir saisi
la république en marche et que ça ne
soit pas remontée
je ne je n'ai pas de commentaires à
faire là-dessus moi même je n'étais pas
au courant et la première ministre l'a
dit elle même dont acte maintenant nous
voyons les faits voyons la suite ne dans
ces cas là vraiment c'est très important
pardon d'insister ne pas préempter et de
ne pas rendre coupable des gens dans des
affaires qui sont graves qui sont
sérieuses ça permet aussi de respecter
la parole de ces femmes de ne pas la
manipuler de ne pas la prendre et de
dire soit elles ont raison sur le saut
elle ont tort nous ne le savons pas donc
c'est la suite et la justice qui
décidera rien d'autre dans un cas comme
celui-ci vous n'était pas partisan du
principe de précaution c'est à dire on
attend voit le temps de la justice pour
rappeler monsieur abad au gouvernement a
beau but à vous me posez une question
sur un sujet que j'ai découvert hier
matin où je crois comme nous tous donc
à voir extrêmement couple en tant
qu'homme bien sûr mais principe de
précaution à partir du moment où le
gouvernement avait été formé ont posé
une question ex post donc par définition
maintenant damien abad et membres du
gouvernement et les mêmes règles doivent
s'appliquer à lui qu aux autres c'est à
dire laissons la justice travailler les
nominations surprise dans ce
gouvernement c'est celle de pap ndiaye
au poste de ministre et ducation
nationale alors c'est une domination qui
fait débat qui suscite des critiques
notamment celles de l'extrême droite
marine le pen dit il défend une
idéologie racialiste en design is ok
c'est un signal inquiétant pour l'avenir
un choix terrifiant qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça je réponds que là encore
on essaie de manipuler les travaux d'un
homme qui est d'abord un historien
brillant reconnu partout dans le monde
faut-il dire on se plaint souvent de pas
avoir de fortes pertes de fortes
personnalités intellectuels reconnus
mondialement
il en fait partie et je crois surtout
que c'est un pur produit de la
méritocratie française et c'est
peut-être ça qui en dérange certains
il est la démonstration que dans notre
pays on peut réussir dans notre pays on
peut justement montrer l'exemple en
terme d'égalité des chances et ce sont
des sujets qu'il veut porter au
gouvernement dans un ministère difficile
où il y aura beaucoup de réformes à
mener on a une éducation nationale qu'il
faut continuer à transformer il a une
feuille de route pour cela je crois
qu'il faut cesser maintenant ses vaines
polémiques suite à la nomination qui
sont portées quand même par des
opposants qui et c'est d'essayer trouver
un petit bout de quelque chose pourra
nourrir des polémiques au moment de la
formation d'un gouvernement vous voyez
bien qu'on a d'abord affaire un homme
brillant reconnu par ses pairs et qui
sera un excellent ministre de
l'éducation
quand il parle de violences policières
vous êtes d'accord quand il parle de
racisme structurel en france je crois
que ce qu'il a dit beaucoup plus
complexe que les raccourcis qu'on a pu
comme souvent malheureusement qu'on a pu
on a pu sortir et
turenne en mai par lequel
suis ni le porte parole de ses travaux
passés ni son porte parole aujourd'hui
et ce qui est très bien c'est que
maintenant qu'il est ministre vous aurez
tout loisir pour l'inviter et lui poser
ces questions là mais vous savez est à
peine de gagner là-dedans or une feuille
de route en tant que ministre qui va
être suffisamment complexe il va tout de
suite rencontré l'ensemble des parties
prenantes qui font le monde de
l'éducation nationale pour réfléchir à
l'avenir de notre école et c'est bien ça
la priorité c'est un vrai choix qu'a
fait emmanuel macron à la loire
gouvernement quelqu'un qui a une grande
liberté de parole est ce qu'il va
pouvoir regarder selon vous est-ce qu'il
doit la garder seront écoutés vous savez
très bien que quand on est membre du
gouvernement on à ce devoir de
solidarité gouvernementale qui est plus
particulier que corps en est un
chercheur effectivement non affiliés
politiquement c'est évident que sa
parole sera par définition moins livre
mais comme tous les ministres vous le
savez ça ne l'empêchera pas de garder sa
personnalité candia ministre ne devienne
pas quelqu'un qui perd toute
personnalité toute capacité d analyse
personnelle je vous rassure donc toutes
ces questions qui vous taraude le
concernant vous aurez tout loisir de
la part des manuels mac ronde
nommer quelqu'un qui est apprécié par la
gauche jean luc mélenchon d'ailleurs à
saluer cette nomination il ya un peu
tactique avant la visite hâtives mais
vous savez à chaque fois qu'on nomme
quelqu'un qui est plutôt appréciée de la
droite on dit ah vous donner des gages à
la droite ces fameux gage qu'on voit
partout et là ça serait des gages à la
gauche je crois qu'on poursuit tout
simplement ce grand rassemblement qui
est la force de ce que porte emmanuel
macron depuis 2010 est il ya des
personnalités effectivement de la gauche
de la droite elles sont toutes
républicaine et universaliste ça rejoint
aussi et ça répond partie à votre
question précédente elle aime à parler
du fond des sujets puisque premier
conseil des ministres se déroule
aujourd'hui au coeur de ses priorités la
politique du gouvernement il ya la
question du pouvoir d'achat est ce qu'un
texte sera présenté au conseil des
ministres avant les législatives opa
soit juste avant soit juste après ce qui
est sûr c'est que le premier texte que
devront voter les députés de la nouvelle
assemblée ce sera le texte pour le
pouvoir
qu'ils le soient juste avant ou juste
après honnêtement c'est un peu
d'importance ce qu'il faut c'est que les
élections non parce que ce qu'il faut
vous connaissez ce qu'il y a deux dans
sa déjà été annoncée par gabriela talent
quand il était porte parole encore de
l'ancien gouvernement on sait que ce qui
compte c'est que les retraites seront ré
indexé sur l'inflation on sait qu'il va
y avoir des aides ciblées notamment sur
la hausse du carburant on sait que le
bouclier tarifaire qui permet de bloquer
les prix du gaz est de limiter la hausse
de l'électricité sera prolongée on sait
qu'on va parler aussi de chaque
alimentaire on sait qu'on va parler de
point d'indicé pour les fonctionnaires
on sait que tout ça sera mis à l'ordre
du jour le détail précis du texte sera
effectivement au tour de l'élection des
députés pour qu'ils puissent être en
capacité de délibéré et de l'adopter le
plus rapidement possible ça c'est une
priorité parce que là pour le coup le
pouvoir d'achat des français lui
n'attend pas et justement pourquoi ne
pas prendre des mesures avant l'été via
des mesures qui sont possibles sans
passer par la loi oui je crois que
d'abord nous avons fait beaucoup
faut-il le rappeler le bouquet tarifaire
est en vigueur aujourd'hui 1
le prix à la pompe diminué de 18
centimes est en vigueur aujourd'hui donc
ce n'est pas comme si rien n'était fait
actuellement par contre il va falloir le
prolonger et pour le prolonger il est
bon aussi en démocratie que nous
puissions débattre donc que le rapport
de force politique soit installée au
parlement et pour cela il faut encore
attendre effectivement quatre semaines
c'est à dire le temps de l'élection
législative
l état est très endetté on le sait aux
sorties pour sortir de cette crise est
ce qu'il va pouvoir plus pour les
français dans cette situation ou
complexes de aux rudiments
internationale aussi oui l'état français
est en capacité de protéger les français
en fonction de la violence de la poussée
inflationniste lié à la guerre en
ukraine la réponse est oui nous pouvons
la france est un grand pays et a les
moyens de protéger ses concitoyens mais
aussi ses petites entreprises à la
question de la dette nous avons toujours
été très clair la dette se rembourse la
dette elle doit être soutenable donc si
nous ne voulons pas augmenter les impôts
il faudra effectivement que notre
capacité à avoir une croissance plus
importante qu'avant la crise puissent
être adoptées pour cela tout ce que nous
avons fait en ayant une entreprise plus
compétitif dans notre pays en ayant une
capacité de produire plus et bien tout
cela sera évidemment une crise majeure
dans notre capacité de remboursement de
dettes il faudra aussi
précisément par la croissance d'abord
mais aussi par une maîtrise de la
dépense publique la maîtrise de la
dépense publique snapap c'est pas ne pas
protéger quand il faut c'est aussi être
en capacité de plus efficient dans cette
époque notamment dans les dépenses de
l'état et ça nous l'avons démontré avant
la crise qu'ovide souvenez-vous entre
2017 et 2019 c'est notre majorité qui a
permis de commencer à désendetter le
pays et bien ce savoir-faire nous
leurrer utiliseront après cette séquence
où nous devons d'abord et
prioritairement protéger nos concitoyens
justement sur ces questions pouvoir
d'achat gérard larcher hier le président
de sénat il faut cibler les plus
modestes on ne peut pas continuer la
politique déchets casque il a raison
mais c'est ce que nous faisons gérard
larcher n'a peut-être pas bien regardé
les textes de protection au pouvoir
d'achat que nous avons déjà voté nous
avons toujours ciblé les plus fragiles à
chaque alimentaire par exemple il sera
ciblé mais il le faut parce que regarder
ce que nous avons fait avec l'indemnité
inflation elle est éligible au moins de
2000 euros de revenus quand on le
faisait on nous disait ah bah parce qu'à
2000 euros en mairie soit là il ya
toujours matière à faire polémique dans
ce pays là je suis rassuré nous vivons
en démocratie ça veut dire que on peut
débattre mais évidemment que le ciblage
aux plus fragiles des aides c'est notre
politique depuis cinq ans et on
continuera l'alimentaire
c'est en discussion un outil du choc
alimentaire il est utile et précisément
parce qu'on peut cibler sur ceux qui en
ont plus besoin mais aussi parce qu'on
peut cibler à destination c'est à dire
peut-être cibler des produits qui
peuvent aussi aider notre propre
industrie agroalimentaire et des
peut-être nos propres producteurs tout
ça ça serait en discussions dans les
prochaines semaines autres sujets en
discussion promis par le gouvernement le
déblocage du point d'indicé pour les
fonctionnaires
là encore un peu de patience vous verrez
le texte dans les toutes prochaines
semaines nous avons un nouveau ministre
de la fonction publique qui vient d'être
nommé on ne peut pas d'un côté reproché
parfois une certaine verticalité au
pouvoir et quand le temps de la
concertation et de la discussion avec
les syndicats avec toutes les parties
prenantes de la fonction publique va
avoir lieu dans les tout prochains jours
prochaines semaines il faut laisser
place à la concertation et vous aurez
ses décisions
sur l'inflation il y aura forcément une
part d'indexation à l'inflation 2 fait
quand il sera revalorisé après est-ce
que durablement il faut une clé
dentition encore une fois ne me demandez
pas d'arbitré aujourd'hui des
discussions qui doivent aujourd'hui
entre nouveau mini soir à saint martin
est rapportage et l'inflation
l'inflation impact le pouvoir d'achat de
tous donc quand nous indexons les
retraites sur l'inflation ça y répond
quand nous parlons de revaloriser le
point d'indicé des agents publics ça y
répond quand ceux du privé ne peuvent
pas en bénéficier
on triple et en pérennise la possibilité
d'avoir une prime macron il y a des
réponses pour tous mais si encore une
fois ne le faisons pas dans la
concertation dans cette nouvelle méthode
qui doit être encore lu dans le dialogue
que ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
présent et bien à ce moment là vous
comprendrez que ma réponse sera
peut-être un peu court circuit tente
pour ceux qui sont responsabilités en
termes d'économie avec un s vous avez
déjà des pistes oui nous l'avons dit
dans le programme présidentiel il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire notamment
dans l'efficience à aller chercher en
termes de fraude fiscale et de fraude
sociale nous pouvons davantage investir
pour récolter beaucoup plus de produit
fiscal là dessus et de lutte contre la
fraude nous avons aussi des économies
dans les ministères a continué notamment
parce qu'on appelle les synergies dans
les back office il ya beaucoup de choses
à faire qui peuvent être menées la
transformation public a mené à médine
monchal a pendant cinq ans sera
poursuivi par stanislas guérini est tous
assez source d'économies mais attention
ne nous faisons pas de mauvaises
illusion ces économies là elles sont
importantes parce que c'est une question
d'efficacité de la dépense publique et
j'y tiens ce n'est pas ce biais là qui
va permettre de financer l'autonomie et
la retraite minimale c'est pour ça que
des réformes structurelles seront aussi
nécessaires à commencer par celle du
départ de l'âge à la retraite qu'il
faudra repousser et qu'elle
notre proposition dans le contrat
présidentiel ses 65 ans sur 10 ans si la
concertation à nouveau et vous
l'entendrez beaucoup dans notre bouche
pendant les prochaines années il le faut
il le faut il faut discuter si la
concertation propose des revoyure
propose d'avoir un rythme et un
calendrier différent personne n'y est
opposée ce qu'il faut ça un cap qui ait
du sens nous nous proposons de
travailler plus longtemps tout au long
de la vie pour financer pour financer un
modèle social qui nécessite de dépenser
davantage d'une retraite minimale
je suis combien les gemmois concertation
les écouter mais moi je suis convaincu
que les syndicats sont d'accord avec le
fait que la retraite minimale doit être
portée à 1100 euros je suis
je suis
que tout le monde dans ce pays surtout
après les scandales orpea que nous avons
vu est convaincu qu'il nous faut un vrai
financement public du grand âge je suis
convaincu que notre modèle social est
souhaitée pour être conservé dans notre
pays par une grande majorité de nos
concitoyens et tout ça ça demande du
financement et donc vous savez les
retraites c'est très simple il ya
quelques levier soit on augmente les
cotisations c'est à dire les impôts soit
en baisse les prestations sociales c'est
à dire les pensions soit un travail un
peu plus nous nous faisons le choix de
travailler un peu plus la question est
de savoir à quel rythme comment on le
fait est là c'est là où la de
concertation doit effectivement
prospérer avec olivier du soft un
ministre du travail qui est connu
justement pour ça qu a pesté dialogue
souvenez vous c'était lui le ministre de
la fonction publique quand nous avons
fait une réforme qu'on nous annonce est
impossible au moment du statut de la
fonction quand ça veut dire concertation
oui mais on ne reculera pas sur un
report de l'âge de départ le président
de la république nous sommes en
démocratie a été élu sur un programme
qui veut faire travailler plus longtemps
pour financer ces nouvelles solidarités
ce cap politique qui nous ne l'assument
ont pas et c'est tout d'un coup nous
reculons ce serait trahir tous ceux qui
ont voté pour emmanuel macron
les collectivités locales alors il n'y a
pas de baisses de dotations prévues pour
les collectivités le reste de la même
manière qu'il n'y en a pas eu pendant
les cinq dernières années nous avons
protégé les finances locales comme
jamais dans ce pays et faut-il le
rappeler entre parenthèses que la baisse
de dotation globale de fonctionnement
pour les collectivités continuent elle a
été faite dans le quinquennat de
françois hollande et donc il ne faut pas
non plus là encore manipuler les
chiffres et les effet d'annonce en
laissant penser que sous emmanuel macron
les collectivités ont été lésés c'est
tout l'inversé
je vais vendre aux ennemis de diminuer
vous répondre
absolument pas il faut que et l'état et
les collectivités participent à la
maîtrise de la dépense publique la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques ce n'est
pas baisser les dotations ce n'est pas
de l'austérité c'est assumer un rythme
un rythme d'augmentation de la dépense
qui puisse être limité
il peut y en avoir d'autres là encore le
dialogue avec les élus locaux est
essentiel là dessus
parce que encore une fois pardon de le
dire ça nécessite d'être clair dans les
termes on ne baisse pas les moyens des
collectivités locales points vous
pourrez en faire le titre de l'émission
on ne baisse pas les dotations des
collectivités locales
on doit travailler ensemble parce qu'il
me semble que ce qui représente
aujourd'hui ces organisations d'élus
locaux la mf la rfa sont plutôt des
personnes qui niveau national reconnaît
ce qu'il faut faire attention à la
dépense publique eh bien tous ensemble
état et collectivités
on limite la hausse en limite la hausse
des dotations de fonctionnement
c'est-à-dire un montant de 10 milliards
la législation c'est ce qui était
proposé dans le programme présidentiel
effectivement encore une fois
discutons-en les collectivités ont pu
bénéficier de l'aide de l'état comme
jamais pendant la crise qu vide les
collectivités locales ont pu bénéficier
de l'aide à l'investissement à travers
des dotations exceptionnelles plus de 2
milliards d'euros que nous avons mis sur
la table pendant la crise moi je veux
bien que l'on parle petites phrases et
polémiques mais il faut aussi
si parce que souvent on ressort dans le
contexte cette phrase d'efforts sur la
dépense publique pour les collectivités
en oubliant assez rapidement bientôt à
valeur des gâteaux à laval et n'ayant
plus de saveur en oubliant un peu vite
tout ce qui a été fait pendant la crise
comme
vous êtes candidat je suis dans le val
de marne absolument tout proche de paris
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment que
rappel cause est noble de gauche et du
parti socialiste est-ce que vous avez
sentiment qu'en cinq ans les choses ont
changé que ça s'est radicalisée dans le
débat
jean luc mélenchon affaire très bons
scores dans votre circonscription oui
jean luc mélenchon a augmenté son score
en cinq ans dans ma circonscription
promis beaucoup lié au vote utile parce
que l'union de la gauche finalement n'a
pas beaucoup évolué en cinq ans dans ma
circonscription mais
probablement qu'une partie du débat
s'est radicalisée oui en cinq ans et
c'est aussi notre responsabilité de
réussir à davantage unir rassembler et
faire en sorte que le débat s'apaisent
ça je vous la corde aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons pas nous satisfaire d'avoir
quatre blocs dans notre pays un bloc
d'abstentionnistes par définition est un
échec démocratique un bloc
mélenchonistes qui par définition est un
échec sur nos valeurs républicaines ou
sur la vision de l'europe ou sur la
vision justement de comment nous pouvons
protéger notre économie est un bloc
d'extrême droite qui reste
malheureusement beaucoup trop puissant
et qui en termes de vivre ensemble
représente tout le contraire de ce que
nous voulons défendre à ce niveau là
évidemment qu'il y ait un constat
d'échec que nous devons absolument
réparer et j'ai beaucoup parlé de
conserver concertation une méthode de
dialogue je suis convaincu
personnellement que ça passe par là
pourrait devenir le premier groupe
d'opposition la tête de la commission
des finances quel serait votre avis
là-dessus
le premier groupe d'opposition seraient
effectivement celui qui obtiendra la
présidence de la commission des finances
c'est ainsi que nos institutions
fonctionnent et donc je suis un grand
démocrate et ce sera évidemment pas à
moi de m'y opposer et nous travaillerons
avec le ou la présidente de la
commission des finances quand nous
serons majoritaires et moi je reste au
service effectivement à la fois de mon
pays de ce que je sais faire le mieux je
crois aujourd'hui l'économie les
finances publiques
nous verrons je vais d'abord commencer
par essayer d'être réélu faisons les
choses
avec vous destinez un dernier mot
puisque vous parlez d'une remise de la
fonction publique cette année samedi et
lundi est-ce qu'il peut rester encore à
la tête de renaissance de la nouvelle
république en marche ou est-ce qu'il
doit quitter ses fonctions est ce que
vous êtes candidat lui succéder non je
ne suis pas candidat à lui succéder
salissage guérini a fait un travail très
difficile avec beaucoup de courage avec
beaucoup d'abnégation et nous lui devons
beaucoup dans le succès de l'élection
présidentielle et de la préparation des
élections législatives à la tête du
parti il a il à la tête d'un grand
ministère très important avec des enjeux
de réformes très lourd je pense
effectivement que lui-même le premier
soit rapaces et la main comme on dit sur
le mouvement qu'on a compris merci
beaucoup merci d'avoir été notre invité
est rapporteur général du budget
candidat aux législatives dans le val de
marne
[Musique]